change is
difficult and you know we're
beings that
like being comfortable in this comfort
zone right getting out of that comfort
zone
is hard and uh it takes a lot of work
and uh it takes a lot of trust and
conviction
and it's one of the hardest things i've
had to do but
when you get to the other side of that
yeah a understanding that you've never
really arrived you always have to
continue to work and we're flawed and
there's an evolution and
uh keeping that humility and being
grateful for for that is important
but yeah i mean look in order to to do
better things you do have to change
we have a problem as a generation i
think right now of denying gratification
we want it right now i don't want to
work for 10 years ago i want two years
i want to be on instagram like that
person have two million followers and
have like money coming in people are
fascinated and they're like really into
it and like they're like
you know they always ask me well how do
you do that i'm like well i mean i i
work all the time and they said when you
work i'm like five in the morning like
five in one i would never do that i'm
like exactly
that's
that's why you're never going to do it
on a long enough timeline no one is
willing to do what i'm willing to do
they will fall off and life has just
taught me that is the [ __ ] gospel
truth we talked about that the try
harder one more time they keep going one
more time and they keep going one more
time and they just keep dropping off
until you're the last man standing or
woman whatever it is a thousand percent
and that's why when you said that i was
like that's intoxicating me that is that
is the very thing that my success is
predicated on is i'm i'm
i'm relentless like let the full weight
of that word wash over you i am
relentless i will not stop i'm like the
[ __ ] terminator don't go into the
selling business i'm gonna repeat that a
second time do not go into the selling
business
go into the reorder business where your
product is so good that you know when
someone buys it yeah they're going to
want to either use it again or recommend
it to somebody else if it's a one-time
service right that's the key to
longevity any business and developing a
product you can have whistles and bells
but if it breaks the next day or doesn't
work sensationally
you don't have longevity my dad when he
said okay you're going to go to houston
you're going to get a football
scholarship
okay
you're going to do this and you're going
to go to the pros okay
you're going to go to you're going to
you're going to
be an all-pro and you're going to go to
pro bowl okay you're going to win the
super bowl he told us that the week
we're getting ready patriots are
undefeated you already won the game son
it's already done
you're going to win the super bowl like
he never said if
[Music]
and i grew up and i remember going
wow
my dad never said if
he truly always said when
which i don't know if he knew what he
was doing
i don't think so i don't think he knew
consciously what he was doing but he
programmed with by always telling me
when in my head if there's something i
want
when it happens it's not if it's gonna
happen
life is short but at the same time like
yeah i think there's it's a very
american thing to get stuck in this idea
of like
well if
i grow up wanting to do this and i go to
college for that
i have to do that forever you know what
i mean right and it's the same with like
athletes veterans all this stuff like
it's not true like you can do 17
different things
and be really good at all of them you
know what i mean like you have to
obviously
commit and like put the work in but it's
never too late i look for things that
happen in magical ways and i look for
this
it'd be interesting to see if you felt
this in racing because a lot of surfers
feel it you know i don't know about i
don't know anything about race car
driving but you know how like when you
surf and you're looking for that perfect
wave and you can get in the zone
anytime you're doing any sort of sport
like that you really get into flow and
what i look for when having ideas
are is this in flow is it easy and
magical things happen like you are in
this
system of flow and
and i just roll with it like okay let's
see what happens and that's what i look
for when it's hard and difficult
i kind of go i don't know about this
right it's
that's a sign to me um
doesn't mean you can't do it
it just means you don't have the
universal flow backing you up right
you have two choices in life really
as you are as an adult
you can choose optimism
this is this this this bottle of water
here
is not full but i'm going to fill it up
or you can choose pessimism there's not
enough water
it's empty
and optimism i choose optimism every
time because
i choose to want to be optimistic and i
choose to want to have good things
happen so when they happen i'm happy in
that stage already if you choose
pessimism you're always thinking
something bad is going to happen and
then when something bad happens you've
already chosen it white so now you have
it a second time right so pessimists you
get two wacks yeah optimism it's just
optimistic yeah if it happens you're
like okay yeah pessimism you're worrying
about it half not happening and then it
doesn't happen and you're screwed right
it's a terrible way to go through life i
agree
now it doesn't really matter
life is going to be what it is but if
you choose optimism i guarantee you you
will make better choices
you will understand what happens to you
better even if it's bad
and you like look at things sit back and
say okay
you know i can handle this this is fine
my second bankruptcy 38 and invested all
my money in this amazing idea that was a
dot-com it wasn't my passion but it was
a good idea again no it wasn't alive for
me but it was a recruiting platform that
matched a person's culture with a
company culture it was 20 years ahead of
its time but it was genius back then you
know but anyway the stock market crashed
lost everything
went into a spiritual sabbatical and
really i was done i was really one of
those moments where i got down on my
knees to god and i tried to kill myself
when i was 21 but after i had children a
family i knew that wasn't an option but
i was like i'm done like god you need to
really take me because
i can't do this anymore i was exhausted
from all the pushing and striving and
going through
and then um
you know i started this path of you know
i read a man search for meaning by
victor frankl and then i was in byron
katie's workshop loving what is
and i found peace and happiness within
my being for the first time in my life
there was no desire for money success
anything
i literally was just at peace i didn't
need money i didn't need wealth before i
thought i needed wealth in order to
be somebody right i thought if i could
ever just get rich then i will feel
worthy within my being
so then poo-pourri came along
and what i realized is if i can lose
everything
that i'm not going to do it the same way
i did it before i'm going to have fun
because
when i lost everything when i was 38 i
looked back and i said what's worse than
losing everything is losing everything
and realizing you didn't even have a
damn good time doing it
right i was exhausted i was burnt out
you know it was horrible so i didn't
have anything so then when i said if i'm
going to go back in business i'm just
going to have fun that's it i'm just
going to have fun i'm going to go with
the flow if it feels good i'm going to
do it if it doesn't i'm not because the
[ __ ] can just get wiped out at any
second
so that was when i began that philosophy
i'm like if it feels good do it and if
it doesn't i'm not